c'est non non
[Musique]
j'ai ici une lettre de madame josette
tous à berlin de verdun qui me demande
je cite
comment va le général gamelin au fait
comment vais-je je tiens elle précisé à
l'intention des jeunes d'aujourd'hui
dont les connaissances en histoire de
france englobe toute la période allant
d'hyères soir à demain matin le général
gamelin et s est habile stratège qui
commanda les forces françaises de
septembre 39 à mai 40
fastoche hélas chère madame tous à
berlin le général gamelin n'est plus il
est mort dans son lit à 25 ans mais
alors direz vous comment se fait-il
qu'un si vaillant soldat soit mort dans
son lit et bien c'est simple regardez
bien je n'ai rien contre les moribonds
mais cette agonie m'insupporte
bon et bien puisque je dérange je vais
aller mourir ailleurs bien oui je lave
ou si le général gamelin est mort dans
son lit si parce que je n'ai pas voulu
qu'il meure dans le mien pardon
[Musique]
fait non non